mendy retard
[Musique]
bienvenue en grande bretagne
je cherche jacob kosminsky
qu'est ce que vous lui voulait c'est mon
frère est-ce que je peux y trouver le
dernier match c'est une espèce d'hôpital
un asile de fous nous avons retrouvé le
corps de mary jane kelly dans la chambre
de votre frère elle était dans son lit
frère n'est pas un meurtre votre frère
est un monstre
si vous voulez garder une bonne image de
votre frère fait demi tour
on a passé deux en russie vous aurez la
chambre voisine
l'éventreur en a après vous regardez
bien
parce que j'y suis
c'est que ça
peut-être que l'éventreur me suis déjà
en permanence et qui me retrouvera où
que je sois
vous voulez servir d'appât
[Musique]